wo ist dein leben
[Musik]
damit gehört lisa offiziell zum
restaurant
das sind aber viele neue fotos setze man
ein bisschen erweitert
sag mal wie lange gibt es das restaurant
eigentlich schon aber es müssten jetzt
zehn jahre sein
ja das sind ziemlich genau zehn jahre
nach wahnsinn das heißt wir haben bei 10
jähriges jubiläum
das heißt wir haben das jubiläum beide
fast vergessen und heiratet bloß nicht
ihr vergesst bestimmten hochzeitstag
was wünscht ihr euch denn zum jubiläum
war keine ahnung doch ich wünsche mir
ein fest mit gesten und musik hört sich
gut an
hey wir haben noch etwas vergessen ein
foto von unserem fußball helden
ist nicht schlimm meint ich dich
natürlich kannst du ein foto von uns
dreien machen klar
ja ja ja ja
[Musik]